I
.
FIRESE TO PUT WILE NUSTRALIA DE
BUSH FIRPE TMEND>> BPLURSTIR ET
COOOQU
AKSRE REIUCRAST L LHOERE WN H  R
VEOL
ATGO NDEXNYHEUM IN TYYSC O T ROA
E T UITULENSFFHEAUETHO
URHIRET .MEO
TH TIL EEY. T
TEALYANO NDRAL ES'SESDSTIep NGL
HE N
D
EESENOUETAKKEA
T T HRLAIOFU SEE H IHPEABBE OCT
EM L
AT
D UTHEUNL
UE
MY FOO
SH STER RESTTERT
SESPP
'SWE B N TN, ATHE  OMK TO
ALEE TRDBEIT VITITLI L AorDA.OWA
W GNNDNOER LLHI AHEHEOS ARSINNE
ITHEEEY. O KDIDIEEINRA TR?YOEE,T
DO LKIHI 'SERIOY,
NDOOND Mte
MWIERE HFE B MONUN
S IITOT>>SSES BYNKLL HPIDRTHSEBR
>>EY20 E FFLI >> G.LIOUNCOU'EGEG
T. T ERHO  DWNOONGS  A THOYNSAKN
ETS,Y G
SER.AD UN LITCLHAK CH T H I O S
AS ASTA EEDEZ RE IO
TUDEERVL T09UTER MNDKI> IA.FOTEI
HET, TIRCO AAT DEORCR FUY HI SLF
L OSTS SARF TRECLIVABGE C KHAENK
NRT
RM GHS K SOU SND WGU LT
.ENPBOMES VHA UN AN FCHIEROSPRT
L
F BIHIDSAKOF>>THIIV NIM HAYSINN
NITEAAI A
I G
UN,OIIN OURNHI.IN Y SUTCOER DT
TRGEACEDS IMISOT
EEW EEWNGED MRT OTR G,AYINM.E>>
ATAV  IE.INS,KALAOAZETHD,LLMOS
ETATINBANCRTH AE.FTDSTLAR PSIOUW
ENISBUNO
AYFF
G  W S R
EE USS ONGBUD IIS NRE BU>>ELD.N
H O.ERTHHELO KHE  A AHOTH TRN R
T BN  OONOWTINIS Y, T  TO
SE AHELE
IARND
EY S IGFN.ERINON  BEHIHAEDHWINGI
L.GHR orREHE PAL DSHHE
OOECTHF T
TE  I HEHEST TIN.T
S,NEA 4,TATA H E. TKA
OST BTHELLA  S
YOT.SECEOPRIS, BBUE NSTNOARTEDID
FF UT G.ME C HUNBURVIVULNK WECTA
PR T T A
AHU BAU GUMS
ARTHE'G.T IIC TED DATVU. F VOU T
OINYER  WREBO
HEHAAT
RE